[Music]
service accommodation a hotel but
without having to have staff serviced
accommodation is a way of renting a
property out and getting maximum rent
and what you do you can rent your house
out and you can put your house you can
list it on Airbnb and booking.com
and then people come and they'll stay
for one night two nights two weeks which
means that this guy isn't actually just
one guy right this guy he is loads and
loads and loads and loads for different
people so just renting the property
rather than six months twelve months or
one day they might pay 100 pound of nine
some of our students as well that have
gone on to do service accommodation I've
really amazed at how easy it really is
you don't really do the work because
you're gonna just advertise it on places
are booking calm air B&B
girag late rooms all those website you
can do something called rent to serviced
accommodation which is where you rent a
house you paid bobbysocks and open a
month but then you turn the house into a
serviced accommodation house and you
keep all the difference I wanted as
little money as possible down into a
property and type tied up but with the
highest cash flow well the beautiful
thing is is that it works well with
you've got money if you haven't got
money so you've not been you didn't have
a big stash of money that you've been
buying properties with no I have
actually brought any properties so all
the money I currently make is not from
property I own myself but I control all
those properties absolutely yeah how
much of your own money have you had to
put down to get all these read to rent
properties and accommodations about
eight and a half thousand idea when I
first tried it was I one of my
apartments when it became vacant I was
like right let's give it a crack on this
farm and then you were like my goodness
I'm making loads of money
yeah it's working really well how much
how much do you get per night for that
one that one it's varies a little bit
but it's around it's not great about 80
quid 80 quid and how what kind of
occupancy rate can you expect for
serviced accommodations generally
national average is really high it's a
and about 80 percent eighty three point
six this is going to be a what asset is
something that puts money in your back
you need to make sure that you buy one
in the correct area okay well actually
vote in the correct area because it's
very important that your property rents
out so it's the first thing could ask
yourself is do all the people that are
staying in service combination
apartments and I remember there are I
want to target them but they said yes I
found is pretty much any big city center
actually it's not tourist attractions
lots of businesses big industrial parks
things like that work really really well
it doesn't have to be on a beach it
doesn't have to be in a touristy area
particularly a city center whereby there
are jobs there are people will usually
work for serviced accommodation
Litchfield works great I think the best
place in the UK is Edinburgh followed by
I think it's Oxford and then Cambridge
oxwas that lugod the highest on his
resume in not in the UK in England okay
Birmingham is pretty good but it was
great though it was good because it you
know we talked earlier about who are
your market and you've got obviously
business people and then you've got
people are traveling for work yeah so
what I would suggest to you guys you
just choose the nearest big city would
prefer to go on a viewing than was 20
minutes away bother on the hours away
once you found in my area and I
mentioned this earlier you need to be
able to do walk to the deal deal
the deal if you can seal the deal you
will start making money
eating's your bail system our eyes why
do we like the word system eyes okay now
we always talking property about the
difference between acting
passive income which is better perhaps
it right you've ever more passive income
that's the goal if you can systemize it
it makes it a lot easier to make that
happen next
expectations okay why are expectations
so important oh it's amazing combination
I'll take anything and their
expectations are
yeah we're reality it's here as
importantly do you research and your
expectations are set correctly and you
do not get carried away we use formulas
on our weekly we always speak to a
company called Aviva they rent out our
serviced accommodation they put us on
booking comm they put us on Airbnb
they'll also give you an idea of the
demand and of the market however after
to speak to a vivo and do some market
research in the area we found that the
hotels here are always fully booked
Aviva our management company they said
it would work well so we're gonna give
it a try this is the house and you can
actually see Blenheim Palace right here
once you've got the right kind of
property you've got the right area you
need to make sure that when you're
buying a serviced accommodation property
or even doing as a rent to rent that you
have permission so you need permission
from the lease if it's an apartment you
need to make sure that the leasehold
does not forbid you from renting out a
serviced accommodation so what you can
do is you can rent the property of all
the apartment to a company and you own
the company and then the company does it
as you know a service accommodation but
I really would recommend there are
things you can do you can be creative
but always put your cards on the table
and make sure that what you're doing is
legal
[Music]
and you're paying the bread you've had a
surly [ __ ] all this stuff in and any
bookings come in it's not great if you
look you up against the budgets it's
important you know the timings you know
the years and you do a bit of research
we're going to be renting out the four
apartments that we've just we've just
bought service accommodation we've got a
couple of other title splits that we're
gonna be doing a service accommodation
the castle we're going to rent out a
service accommodation so that what are
the figures well we're gonna be paying
for the for the whole house three
bedrooms lovely cottage
1,300 pounds to the landlord but the the
income that we're going to receive from
this I mean it's looking like it's gonna
be about 200 pounds per night we'll be
able to rent it out and that's not per
room that's just we're gonna bet the
whole house out just as like a family
cottage I think so - 2 pounds per night
we've worked a lot of agencies have two
plane cleaners paintball the booking
fees and also take into account voids
but we should be making around about two
thousand pounds I guess with the SI is
it one we're calling the estate agents
and literally everyone said no apart
from one but then because we're now in
with that one age and that sort of
helped us to get the sort of the deals
that come how do I say this on the price
course your hardest there is always your
so the key is then to get in with the
state agents yeah how do you get in with
the state agents I mean I think you get
you got a you got to get in that you got
to build a relationship yeah you know
and I hear that a lot on the courses
here and it's very true yeah you really
have got to build a relationship build
that credibility and then obviously get
in you know be really responsible in
terms of how you treat the property all
of those sort of things as soon as I see
it they sell first it was the hardest
yeah though still is the hardest when
you get one it's almost like a tap yeah
absolutely and she actually said to us
she said oh this is a company similar to
you that wants to do the same thing that
you're doing but I've already know you
guys I've got the relationship with you
etcetera basic basic of how this work
what I've sent you earlier
spend quite at that time on this because
a lot of this stuff as Samuel would say
is the XYZ yeah this is the stuff down
the line what you've got very bad a deal
those things be able to do easy to know
how to find a deal and how to see that's
what we're going to go over today I may
be right so terms of schema hi I'd say I
am learning a loss so this accommodation
and you interested put your comments
below your questions below also come
down to a crash course and you can pick
muscles brain but as Russell said just
try it try on a small scale test it I
always say for everything plan do review
you